the lottery speaker I involved with
students of tim roughgarden and now as
the Technion and excited thank you very
much
so I'm really glad that my talk is
following yesterday's a half-baked ideas
session I think it can be kind of viewed
as extended the pitch in that session
and I'm really looking forward to
hearing your thoughts one word about my
background so I'm a theoretical computer
scientist and this talk might be kind of
biased it's probably going to be kind of
biased towards that perspective I do
have legal background and undergraduate
degree in law and when the earth
it's practicing law many years ago still
I think that experience is kind of what
makes me really enthusiastic about this
potential collaboration between the
fields so this talk is based on ongoing
discussions with a bunch of people
Joseph Nev I have a shaft phenom al the
organizers of this workshop and many
others of course any errors are my own
Oh
so the main question I want to talk
about today is could there be such an
academic research area as algorithm
design in law and then specifically
focusing on algorithm design and not CS
in general so you can see in this
picture kind of one of the classic
textbooks of algorithm design the reason
for this focus is first of all you know
to make the discussion manageable and
not you know to high-level that we can't
really say anything concrete and second
that I think there's untapped potential
here and this is something I hope to
convince you during during the talk or
let's see what you think okay so the
starting point is that as we as we all
know
technological developments can serve as
triggers for new fields of study and I
have I want to start with a couple of
examples here are two examples from
within the discipline of law so the the
development of the legal right to
privacy to my understanding followed
technological developments like
photography like recording sound and
like the widespread circulation of
newspapers this was you know 130 years
ago so there is a lot of many decades
here of legal thought that hopefully as
computer scientists we can tap into
another example more recent one is
cyberspace the internet triggering the
need to consider code and its regulatory
role so work of Lawrence Lessig around
in nineteen on code is law this is uh
this is another example mostly within
law here's another example that's
between two disciplines computer science
and economics algorithmic game theory is
actually my main research area so the
technological development here was very
similar to the previous example the
Internet's more specifically online
markets so what happened is that
computer scientists kind of found
themselves engaging in in market design
right if you worked at Google and you
were designing auctions for online
advertising you're basically doing micro
economic market design and more more
generally algorithm design is in
strategic environments in this kind of
creative the need for guiding theory and
I'm bringing this example right at the
start because I think this is an amazing
example of hugely successful
collaboration so now nowadays and this
is my main research area as I mentioned
and I interact daily with economists my
main venue for publication is joint
conference on economics and computation
call DC so by the way come
sign this you probably know this but the
target conferences is May publication of
nu and I'm kind of wondering if this
could be like like kind of blueprint
that we can follow for law and algorithm
design I'll mention some caveats okay so
we saw a few examples of technological
developments serving as triggers for new
fields of study and what's happening now
is that uses diff algorithms in society
is basically exploding algorithms are
infiltrating and governing to large
extent almost every aspect of her life
both as individuals in a society and I
think one way to view differential
privacy and fairness is as two research
fields that arise out of this okay so
very briefly kind of near the same
language the technological development
that drove differential privacy can be
seen as increasingly detailed electronic
information about individuals which
created the need to define what it means
for an algorithm to be private and then
you know come up with a bunch of
algorithms that are actually fulfilling
this definition and exactly the same
thing for or very similar for fairness
increasingly accurate algorithmic
predictions which raise the need to
define mathematically to find rigorously
defined fairness and hopefully have
algorithms that satisfy these
definitions okay so with these example
examples in mind we can take a step back
and kind of more generally look at the
technological development of algorithms
having very far-reaching effects today
on societal values privacy fairness and
more as I hope to demonstrate and then
the new theory needs is you know
theoretical guidance for algorithm
designers who are basically engaging in
social engineering that
used to be within the realm of law okay
so to kind of recap the the question is
it time for a wider academic
collaboration on algorithm design that
law may be in the same style of
algorithmic game theory and kind of the
more specific questions we need to ask
ourselves are what would be the scope
and content of such a collaboration and
what are the potential gains and
challenges okay so as I said this talk
is kind of initial ideas initial
thoughts the goal is to facilitate a
discussion and to looking forward to
viewpoint is kind of bias towards you
know my own background and I will try to
not really talk about fairness and
privacy but rather about other examples
okay one thing I want to mention is that
I'm not really going to be talking about
what's sometimes referred to as
computational law or AI in service of
law and this includes things like
automated automated dispute resolution
legal reasoning text mining knowledge
representation ego vermin and so on so
this is both to keep the discussion
focused also because these are areas
that are have already been addressed to
a large extent their existing
communities dedicated conference like I
sell and so on okay questions up till
now
okay so a little bit more motivation why
is this the right time to have this
discussion so I think both disciplines
can have a lot to gain so computer
scientists you know there's this huge
body of literature and and sods that we
can tap into like like in privacy for
many other areas and maybe you know what
is the most motivating for us is you
know new problems that we can kind of
apply our tools and our way of thinking
to and this is I think maybe one of the
main goals of this workshop right
surfacing new problems for us to to
address law on the perspective from the
perspective of legal scholars I think
it's an opportunity to kind of expand
existing legal legal doctrines and get
inspiration from other approaches that
are maybe more mathematical more
mathematical more rigorous and kind of
more bluntly I feel that each community
really needs the other right now to stay
relevant right because we can write we
can you know have our definitions
mathematical definitions but if they're
not if we want to actually apply them
they should follow they should
algorithms need to be legal first of all
and and and we don't want to miss this
opportunity and then on the other side
if if the fact though you know algorithm
designers are encoding legal doctrines
then this is this is where the action is
happened is happening
I think the Omo Omo put it much more
nicely than the night then I can so
here's here's the site here's a quote
computer scientists cannot solve
algorithmic fairness and any other issue
of this sort on their own these issues
cannot be seriously considered without
major involvement of compute
scientists and what we need is a true
collaboration rather than kind of one
community subcontracting for the other
yes yeah no because I want to bring
myself and those of us who are not
lawyers
neither computer scientists right and I
want to just remark that you're itself
has to confront certain compromises in
what it can and cannot address or what
what it should not address because it
because subject to various constraints
like impossibility for example so I
wonder if you wanna turn and I'm looking
at what your mayor said I I don't see
the word law in game you're just saying
we can't do all of this on our own so
it's fine I think it's that's a good
thing to look at law and computer
science and see how that you can kind of
collaborate them reinforce and so forth
but I also want to leave some room to
say that the normative spadework
also has to go beyond into the empirical
social sciences and
maybe philosophical antics yes I could
in the next now I think that maybe if we
talk not about blow but about norms you
know that could allow the discussion of
ethics and behavior yeah highly
problematic in a sense yes yes I think
there's a triangle here there is what we
want to implement is kind of normative
standards that come from ethical
philosophy social science and we have
tools for implementing them and these
tools are both legal tools we need to
understand the relationship between all
these the three interpretation we need
to make sure that the legal standards
also match what would
is thinking about additional things and
they took your son speaking matches that
and also the mismatch which one
thanks so much for these comments yeah
no I think we can expand also in the
discussion but I totally agree okay
you're kind of signs of tightening
collaboration for the past year or so
there's going to be a cm event on
computer science in law this is
happening in October in New York the
aims are particularly to bridge the
divide between CS and law to stimulate
interest in this emerging field sort of
tickle eight a research agenda and see
how the ACM can be part of this
I put the topics on this slide in case
people are curious there's a bunch of
things here within kind of computational
a lot that I said I wouldn't talk about
that they're a bunch of things that seem
highly relevant to this particular talk
another kind of one of these signs is
joint courses for law students and CS
students one of them happened last year
jointly in Berkeley Boston University
Columbia and Harvard and it was a little
bit more focusing on maybe I guess
crypto your ability proofs and so on but
this also seems a very relevant there is
the ongoing the second year already fat
star conference this is I present I
presented there this year and this is
from the speaker instructions that we
got that I found both of using and very
helpful so the kind of we're very
explicit about you know computer
scientists please note that we're
encouraging you to defer the technical
details okay so I meant
this because it seems to me maybe also
kind of a warning sign a little bit for
example when I compare this to you to
the ec conference that I mentioned there
I'm very welcome to talk about the
technical aspects of my work so
something to keep in mind and then there
are multiple additional events I think
Nicole will mention some inert comments
including of course this workshop okay
now right okay thank you so the comment
was about the privacy tools project and
at Harvard just there's a warning sign
there but you know you see is not it's a
great venue but it's not not as
interdisciplinary like the different the
difference in perspective between
mechanism designers and algorithm
designers is like not that I mean
speakers improve see exactly so much
less of a gap between them there is
between different kinds of Economist's
right right I agree and I think you know
this is a on one hand we kind of have to
collaborate this is my feeling on the
other hand it's going to be hard so this
is right this is gonna be hard but I
would change this suggestion to try to
to find a language that will allow us to
jointly work on the technical right
right right and I think like avoiding
sugar technical difference to the
lawyers or to prospers is not going to
solve the problem they will keep working
different
without having nowhere to run we must
find a way to communicate over the
technical details I think maybe some of
the the similarity between mechanism
designers and computer scientists these
days is to the hindsight of a 20 year
old yes I tend to agree but still it's
the basic language in math which is so
this is very interesting because I'm
general co-chair of the next ACF and
we're gonna take this home I think that
a simple that is very focused on impact
so what's the impact of all these
fantastic designs in one thing's there's
very important where this community is
that these problems cannot all be solved
by computational techniques so the fear
of having technological fixes and
everybody presenting deeply interesting
computational papers without showing why
these technical details matter in terms
of impact so I think what I like is what
you said that the technical details may
precisely be what makes that difference
I would just say also that fat star is
in some sense trying to be a home for
things that many people in this room and
outside this room would say are not
sufficiently technically novel for
places like UC for places like Europe's
and ICML where you aren't necessarily
developing a brand new algorithm that
beats some benchmark on some task but
saying something different about some
and I think that that's something that
computer scientists especially
theoretical computer scientists the
computer scientists in general tend to
not find they say it's an observation as
opposed to technical novelty but what if
I'm greedy and I want both I want both
do you know of the novel side okay I
think one more comment than this it was
gonna be about privacy enhancing
technology symposium which is very
interesting because it actually
deliberately sometimes contests the law
and talks about the shortcomings of the
law especially in the case of
surveillance and government surveillance
so they are not interested in just
normatively implementing all or being
legal in fact sometimes it's like law
will fail us and no and I think that's
also important to see is another way of
approaching law I'm not saying it's the
only way but like then I I have to also
say that as a reviewer for at
conferences the papers that I saw gave a
complete misrepresentation of the law to
such an extent that I said don't ask me
again because the people the authors
then respond to all the technical
commence and they say yes to my comment
oh very good we've inserted one sentence
in jail
freeze so this is a very big problem
first to misrepresent the law and then
to say the law does everything wrong
that gives us nowhere like so
I do hope there may seem fat it's not
going into that line of thought and I
think it's a real challenge for all
computer science conferences okay so um
here's a comparison between algorithmic
and legal doctrine
okay I keep talking about Al garden
design would it be a bit more specific
about what I mean
here's a picture of an algorithm we have
input and then the algorithm is that
computational steps that map input to
the output there's going to be some
objective okay that we want to reach
when we're mapping input to output
and constraints both computational which
are more classic thing we tend to
take into account as I'm algorithm
designers okay how many steps do I need
to reach from input to output what kind
of memory do I need and so on and also
these societal legal constraints that
are more more our focus right now and
just mentioned that algorithms may use
learning a big part of motivates up this
new era here's an example to make this
more concrete
so self-driving self self-driving car
self-driving the policy the input would
be some data that's that the car senses
maybe what other cars are on the road
what's their speed position and so on
the output is the next action to take
maybe if you want to press the brake or
not the objective well there there could
be different objectives list just for
concreteness pick making progress along
the route wanna take and then the
constraints are both these computational
constraints of scalability right you
want to be very you want to be able to
drive in a road with the huge number of
other cars and then the more legal
concern or societal concern is the
safety of others okay typically this
might be learned through reinforcement
learning okay so that was an example of
an algorithm now when I say algorithm
design or as an academic field of
research what do I mean so our main
concern here is to find good algorithms
or show that none exist for various
computational tasks and what do I mean
by good algorithm so another way to
phrase this question is how do I compare
between different algorithms and decide
that one is better than the other let's
consider for example two algorithms from
this area of self-driving cars let's say
that if you apply one of them you get
very quickly between two cities if you
apply the other one you are doing a
great job of driving within a big city
while maintaining your constraints of
scalability and safety which one of
these is better okay and the main kind
of approach
that we take to the question is called
the worst-case approach meaning that we
judge every algorithm by its worst-case
input okay so if we have an algorithm
that just does a great job with in big
cities it's not enough for us because we
want algorithms that are very robust we
want to our self-driving cars to be able
to get us anywhere okay like a human
being would okay
no uh to complement the picture oh okay
thank okay so there's this saying hard
cases make bad law which is basically so
sometimes you have legal doctrine that
is working really well and you know in
almost all cases but then that one case
that gets to court has just
circumstances that are unbelievable you
know you you want to basically bend the
rules
to get to a result that anything else
just seems unfair and this is kind of
referred to as hard cases make bad law
right you don't you want you want some
sort of flexibility in the legal rule
that will allow you to address
circumstances that really are extreme
but you don't want to change the whole
norm right now
I think Nicole will have more to say
about this not at all subscribe to this
because a lot of the development of the
law comes from hard cases in making
being able to make a difference between
a heart and an easy case is itself
requires certain normativity
that is very interesting and keep small
adapt to to circumstances right okay I
think we'll have more yeah definitely
definitely have more to say here I mean
there is something about this that you
want to leave room for things that maybe
you didn't foresee where as an algorithm
is supposed to be robust to everything
right okay definitely coming from the
case law perspective okay
so let's compare to legal doctrine in
the same same kind of area self-driving
cars
so a legal view of the same scenario
could be that you know you have
different drivers on the roads they all
have a right to use the road there are
kind of competing values here you want
useful transferred transportation on one
hand you want safety on the other hand
and what the legal doctrines will do is
kind of balance between these competing
rights and competing values and here's
an example of the negligence doctrine so
this is really in a nutshell and might
not be very precise but just so we see
it an example so the idea is that
drivers should avoid being negligent
meaning not taking precautions that
would cost less than the expected
damages and they should do so where
there is a duty of care
okay so duty of care is kind of the
open-ended place where we can balance
these this competing right and rights
and values damages me like expectation
it doesn't mean expectation so there's a
like a formula there's there's almost a
formula basically called the learned
hand formula which it compares these two
things it is not very precise I mean you
can I mean you wouldn't expected damages
right so it does take into account
probabilities but exactly so you can be
you narrow or wide or so definitely this
is this is precise but not
kind of not not what you were used to in
algorithm design okay where's the loss
in many the link is expose approach and
this is like one of the reasons a lot of
day there's a lot of uncertainty and
table actually things are taking into
port and then the reader Presidium or as
we try not to get to the point where you
have to go to that word I think that
it's really important also to just put
this in the context of the institution's
what is really missing in this
description of the law especially when
we talk about open and the terms is who
is doing this right
never there are there is an
institutional structure like you've
mentioned before right mrs. Zuno and the
institutional structure is inherent in
this system it's not the system that
simply looks at two words and tried to
figure them out I was but there is an
institution legislature report there is
there are authorities there are
processes that they are well defined and
this is how it is beaming so this is I
think that and that is part of the you
know of understanding you know what it
needs to complain you like like norms
and you know rules and open-ended norms
you know maybe to add the core of the
rule of law is the fact that the entity
that enacts the law doesn't get to
determine the interpretation and it
might seem that what would be more
obvious and
then to say well this is the Democratic
legislature day decided to roll so let
them decide the interpretation right
that would be that's good but like three
four five hundred years ago we decided
that that's a very bad idea because it
leads to arbitrary role but it
complicates this in an interesting way
so I would be very interested at some
point to see how computer science would
think about that this idea that you
write an algorithm and then you don't
get to decide where it goes wrong and
how it should be adapted for instance I
want to show three case studies kind of
bring their discussion more concrete
examples of algorithms being shaped by
legal doctrines and vice versa I'm going
to talk the most about the first case
study because I think it's the most well
studied and then the other to mention
more briefly okay so high level idea is
we saw we saw our example of
self-driving algorithm we had these
these constraints one of them was safety
should this constraint mathematically
formulate the legal doctrine of
negligence and you can ask the same
question for almost any algorithmic task
that has implications to to societal
values ok so here's some examples should
we try to interpret the negligence
doctrine and then write that into the
mathematical constraint so I had what
you were saying now in mind what you
were saying now this is what I had in
mind here are some examples and the
first two were things that you know so
so I hope it will make it clearer so we
have for example data analysis affecting
privacy you can have a mathematical
formulation and then mathematical
formulation of that
relevant legal doctrine okay so it's not
clear that this is actually what
differential privacy is but there is
something going on in law something
going on in math the algorithmic tasks
can be subject to the mathematical
formulation yes I don't see the legal
doctrine of rights of privacy in this as
I understand it used in the u.s. really
having almost anything to do with
differential privacy right that's a good
yes I can have sex with whoever I want
and make sort of choices medical choices
behind closed doors for example and
differential privacy Google you know
should or my lender should do something
okay so I mean definitely this is not
trying to describe reality but there is
a there is a possible connection there
and should we should this should there
be this gap or maybe you want either the
mathematical formulation or legal side
or both to change and become closer same
question for fairness okay we have want
to predict something
currently there are multiple notions of
fairness there's definitely relevant
doctrines in law the two examples that
I'm going to talk about right now are
driving safety negligence and an initial
proposal for mathematical formulation
and another example of pricing antitrust
free markets and using formulation from
economics
Niva talked about content moderation
which i think is another example that
kind of you can look at it in this way
mathematical formulation to my knowledge
is is largely open I think maybe because
this has mostly been addressed in an
industry but I think these are like
interesting questions to follow up on
yes
one of the use cases might flavor is
also something that never had great
switches like the digital rights
millennium app act as an attempt to I
don't know represent in force you know
turn ative to legal regulation my back
relationship is interesting right I
agree there's no so what's happening
with Europe in terms of data privacy a
copyright P their copyright one is
requiring companies to do automatic
content filtering cut automatic content
copyright detection so they're the laws
requiring some sort of enforcement by
algorithm right and also GTR others I
think the connection to differential
privacy is maybe close okay let me show
the first case study
um how much time do I have okay I'll try
to go over this quickly but I want to
see a concrete example the paper I'm
going to talk about is by Shelly
Schwartz and it all it's called on a
formal model of safe and scalable
self-driving cars the first and third
authors are also the cofounders of one
sorry founders of mobile I which is a
company that actually does right now
self-driving cars so they're what they
propose here has actually been
experimented on with real cars on the
road real self-driving cards and it
seems to work making it very interesting
the main goal of their paper is to
introduce a model that formalizes an
interpretation of duty of care from tort
law okay this is a quote from their
paper they call it RSS for
responsibility sensitive safety it's
designed to achieve the goals of
compatibility with human and
interpretation of the law usefulness
so not the driving should it be to over
defensive and then also tractable
verification which is interesting from
computational point of view as one of
the things that they want to achieve
they want that if all the agents follow
this policy then there will be no
accidents what you would expect okay
they set out to formalize five
common-sense rules don't hit someone
from behind don't cut in recklessly and
so on and I want to show you the
simplest example of their model let's
say we could just have a single lane
straight road and two cars driving
forward and let's see how their
formulate the duty of care so they have
parameters they have reasonable response
time maximum reasonable Excel
acceleration maximum reasonable break
minimum reasonable break and then they
have a definition of safe distance
okay forgiven villa given velocity is
given speeds if the car of the two cars
okay and the definition is as follows
it's gonna use the parameters let's
assume that the yellow car breaks at a
rate that is at most the maximum allowed
one maximum reasonable one let's say
that the red car has some response time
in which it might be accelerating at
reasonable rates okay it maximum
reasonable rate after the response time
it starts to break ok the minimal
minimum reasonable rate if all this
happens the red is guaranteed not to hit
the LOV have the safe distance between
okay any questions on the definition a
small question so this is an isolated
picture there involves two cars with one
lane about the real
of course very different so does that
feed into the definition somewhere or
what's amazing to me is that the same
kind of definition generalized to you
know in the paper they show a lot of
really complex other scenarios that
basically the same definitions when
they're generalized appropriately seem
to work and actually work somehow in
practice okay now so I have one
definition of safe distance I'm also
going to define as proper response of
the red car if once the safe distance
once the two cards are within the safe
distance and if the yellow one breaks
then the behavior is like it says here
so basically maybe the response time you
still accelerate but right after that
you break it reasonable reasonable rate
okay the claim is that if the red car is
properly responding to the first
violation of safe distance it's
guaranteed not to hit the yellow car
everything is under the assumption that
these parameters are being are holding
in practice okay so that the yellow one
is not breaking to you too fast and so
on okay you can see that the way these
definitions this is maybe relating to
your question the way these definitions
were formulated it allows you to verify
that one car is properly responding to
the other kind of pairwise so when you
you you can evaluate the behavior of the
car of the car the self-driving
algorithm relative to the other car they
kind of call it a star-shaped
computation which makes it much more
computationally efficient so does that
mean that if the yellow car is
responding to this pedestrian who
suddenly crosses the road that this is
that you don't have to take that into
account because it is already
incorporated in your anticipation of
possible behavior of the yellow car this
is it somehow they will have definition
of properly responding to the car and
probably responding to the pedestrian
there will not be a
the contradiction between them as an
example of not not good definition they
give what if you still had this very
simple scenario but the yellow car was
supposed to accelerate a little bit if
the distance between the cars becomes
too small well then you know imagine a
third car before the yellow car
this might exactly so this might be
imposing on the yellow car both the duty
to brake and the duty ticks all right
this is not what they want they want a
non contradiction non contradicting
definitions of reasonable behavior
towards every other car in the road
separately okay
and also the formal proof of this in
this case it's really simple but it
becomes much more complicated the formal
proof is by induction which is also
something that they see as kind of
helping for helping get scalability this
as I mentioned generalize to really
complex scenarios which they have in
their paper so multiple lanes driving in
both directions junctions and
pedestrians basic basically everything
you can think about to me the most
amazing thing is that it works it seems
to work in experiment and experiment
maybe it's not as surprising right
because actually cars I mean humans do
drive and apply some standards of safety
that that work that work and we're
definitely computationally bounded and
so on some other takeaways from this
case study so do you agree that proper
response formalizes duty of care okay
this is definitely what they claim it's
not clear to me that this is actually
what it's doing also it's interesting to
me that this duty of care definition
does take into account computational
tractability and the last point is the
choice of parameters right we mentioned
these parameters a reasonable break time
break rate acceleration rate response
time and so on these are really somehow
encoding a trade-off between the
competing values right between being
able to track
to have useful transportation and safety
and kind of has something to keep in
mind towards our third case study is
that the parameters can't take can be
personalized almost okay they can take
into account whether the driver is human
or robot road conditions and maybe maybe
even more okay yes all day does this
mean like there could never be accidents
or does this mean like in the event of
an accident you would say that the cars
have not engaged in negligent behavior
yes everybody stop
you know the car in front of you from
exploding so know if you go back to the
actual definition a few slides right
like the definition here of like safe
distance sorry yeah like sort of a
incorporates some notion of what you
would assume like reasonable is as well
so it's like it's hard for me to
separate I think this is why it's the
second thing that you said right so if
other people are not behaving reasonably
there might could be a crash you would
not be responsible by definition you're
not responsible I guess what if I just
reflect onto my own driving you know
these there are some like heart
parameters here that I'd like there's
these all these numbers are gonna depend
on the vehicle that's in front of me all
these numbers are numbers are you know
row a X M right right and there are
there types of vehicles like a sedan
where I had like some sense of what
those numbers are cuz there may be some
one comparable to like me but then if
there's like a big truck or a tractor
I'll like treat it very differently I'll
just give it a lot more space because I
just don't really understand what it's
like exactly so you want your algorithm
to be the same or maybe if that Alberto
could you predict better it's gonna be
more efficient right so I see I'm gonna
more or less out of time so should I you
kind of wrap up
the talks and so when I you talk for
another three minutes okay so let me let
me show you in the level let me let me
mention at the level of kind of what
what the topic is with the two other
case studies I wanted to mention are the
first one is collusion by pricing
algorithms there's a really interesting
paper that basically shows that if you
let algorithmic pricing algorithm you
let algorithms learn how to price
separately without communicating they
learn to collude where collude collusion
is according to an economic the finition
of it this would be a graph that shows
it and what I kind of wanted to say
about this case study is that definitely
we want to encode into the algorithms
into the learning pricing evidence a
constraint if not non collusion without
hindering their flexibility to be
efficient too much this is a really
challenging problem actually the current
law just circumvents this entirely by
forbidding only explicit collisions here
are the algorithms as I said they're not
communicating when they learned to
collude so you know the current law
doesn't seem to capture this so it's an
interesting example of where you might
need to revise algorithms in law and at
the same time okay and the third case
study I wanted to show you is up till
now we kind of saw how algorithms might
be getting closer to legal doctrines and
encoding them in some sense what about
the other direction okay so what if the
law wanted to get closer to what an
algorithm would look like in particular
have input okay this has been studied
under the title of personalized law
I think initiated in 2014 there are some
compelling examples which I won't go
into and I think the kind of vast
experience we now have in computer
science
personalization its implications to
fairness to privacy and so on could be
very relevant to this attempt of law and
ultimately probably you know if you have
really if you do have a personal ID law
it will probably be implemented as an
algorithm okay so where we've reached
the discussion I think I'll finish by
showing you this slide of what might be
challenges to collaboration and then and
then kind of hear from Nicole and from
you so as we've been discussing it seems
that you know in some sense the approach
of algorithm design in law is very
different a the worst case approach
could be too restrictive this is one
kind of question I wanted to raise and
on the other hand the open endedness of
some laws could be to inform of informal
for us to capture using algorithms I
went to mention the work of cobby and
that is attempting to bridge these gaps
and also a fever about trying to extract
rules from these open-ended laws and
well sometimes we run we try to
formalize the important things that we
want the algorithms to achieves and we
just run into impossibility results okay
so you all know the incompatibility of
natural fairness notions there's a very
recent paper of Kobe and the lone EF
that they chose that if you take this
notion of security getting singling out
it doesn't really self-composed which is
something we would have expected okay so
these kind of impossibility results
might stop advancements the issue of
mathematical modeling which have already
mentioned and then also auditing which
is a huge issue and this is more or less
it
right so we've seen how algorithms are
currently kind of doing what used to be
within the realm of flaw balancing among
values and doing this it's kind of
social engineering within CS I think
this opens up new avenues for research
and algorithm design and they I'm going
to show two examples of trying to
formalize negligence and antitrust and
between CS and law it seems there's you
know big potential but also big
challenges so we're super lucky to have
nicole ozer give us the commentary on
this nicole is technology and civil
liberties director at the aclu of
california so perfect to tell us good
morning everyone
i'm so really nice to be able to join
you this morning and respond to involves
really important inquiry is it time for
a wider collaboration between computer
scientists and particularly folks who
are working on algorithms and the law so
spoiler alert my response is
resoundingly yes it would be great to
have sort of wider collaboration um but
I have to read three friendly amendments
to what involves sort of been talking
about and actually many of you already
touched on several of the things I was
gonna say so I feel like I was on the
right track so that's good so for a
little bit of context about my approach
before I discuss sort of the three
friendly amendments I'm Nikole ozer just
a little bit of background I was sort of
on the leading edge of students here at
Berkeley that were trained in Public
Interest technology I went to Berkeley
law in 2000 and graduated in 2003 I'm a
lawyer so obviously I come from that
approach so don't take it against me and
for the past 15 years I have been
leading the ACL u--'s intersectional
work on technology and civil liberties
here in California so I've been involved
in work in the courts work in the
your work with companies and also work
with communities on the ground on issues
that are affecting them and particularly
being embedded within the ACLU means
that I've worked on really all of our
cross-functional teams on intersections
of Technology and racial justice
immigrants rights reproductive justice
economic equality sort of all the
different issues that we're talking
about and involve really talked about
that algorithms are really affecting so
much in civil society I am also on
sabbatical right now so I'm on
sabbatical this spring from the ACLU and
I'm really fortunate to actually be
visiting at Berkley law and I'm also
doing a non residential fellowship this
year at Stanford to be studying how to
create better intersections what are the
opportunities and what are the
challenges of creating more
collaboration between people who are
real experts on digital issues and
individuals who are working on broader
civil society issues so this was an
exciting proposed hole that sort of I
read and and I'm really looking forward
to sort of more collaboration so my
three friendly amendments really come
from this perspective of the work that
I've been doing for the last 15 years
and what I'm currently studying on
sabbatical so so first yes there should
absolutely be a wider collaboration but
as as Helen already said absolutely I
think that that should be a wider
collaboration not just between CS and
algorithms and lawyers but a wider
collaboration between not only in the
academic sphere between folks who are
working on law and technology but also
all the social science all the folks who
are real experts on the issues of what's
going to be affected by AI and
algorithms and broader than just the
academic perspective you know the issues
that we're talking about really touch on
all aspects of society health democracy
education and I feel like we really need
the wider input and collaboration of
folks who really understand what the
impact is on the ground
as well as in different academic
disciplines I'd have to say as a lawyer
I know that a lot of our scholarship is
actually relatively disconnected from
what happens in the field and what
happens in other disciplines there are
many good collaborative folks at many
campuses but generally I'm really
looking to this collaboration to be
beyond just the law and beyond just
academia I think if not we really end up
talking past each other and we aren't
building things that actually make sense
from all those disciplines and actually
make sense for what the impact is on the
ground my my sort of second suggestion
is that whatever proposals are put
forward should really be built on many
of the conversations that are already
happening so ACM that you know is being
chaired by Pam and Danny there's
obviously been some joint courses that
are in motion but there's really a lot
happening at institutions and I think
much of that has been siloed some of us
know about things happening on one side
some of us thing know about things
happening at the other Deirdre has been
organizing a really great project
working group here on campus called a
fog about algorithmic fairness and
opacity working group I think it's a
great example of sort of trying to build
across the disciplines the AI now
Institute in New York has been doing
really interesting research on this area
Peter Eckersley who is formerly at EF F
is now the research director at the
partnership and I on AI and is looking
at some really interesting
intersectional work as well and
literally every week I get a call from
another organization that's planning
another event to talk about these issues
like both Aspen and the future of
humanity are doing events next week on
this issue
so there's a lot moving I think one of
the most exciting opportunities I think
just recently is last month it was
announced that there's this new Public
Interest Technology University network
which is bringing together 21
institutions across the u.s. it's a
partnership to really think about how do
build and support more Public Interest
technology and collaborative
infrastructure so it's it's at Berkeley
it's a Stanford
it's a Georgetown it's at Howard it's
sort of around the country and I think
that hopefully that might actually
provide some seed support for more of
this collaborative work across
institutions um the third sort of
friendly amendment is I've been in a lot
of general conversations where we never
get to what are some of the more precise
opportunities for us to collaborate
across disciplines and so to really
think and do some hard work about what
are some where are some real places
where we could actually get together and
do really useful working groups I'm so
broader than just privacy or autonomous
vehicles but really precise questions I
think that when we're when we're
approaching those precise questions this
was brought up earlier that you know
code is law law is also law and law
doesn't build itself it doesn't auto
update it doesn't cover many things in
order to create law you actually have to
have social movements and energy to
actually change that law and so to
really think critically about what are
the opportunities and what are the
limitations of each discipline and that
we can't each necessarily get to where
we want to go alone we have to sort of
think about what are the what are the
best we can pull from certain
disciplines where are things that we
just can't address with certain
disciplines and and come to that
conversation really in sort of active
listening and learning mode and not in
persuasion mode which is often very hard
for those of us who are trained as
lawyers to not be persuading the other
group that actually our mechanism or our
mode is the way to really solve this
problem but to really actively listen
and hear where our opportunities that we
can pull from those different
disciplines because I think when we're
in them
would we actually find that there's much
more similarity than we might have
anticipated just yesterday in ball and I
were talking about this and about this
presentation and she talked to me about
the worst case scenario in terms of
building algorithms which I was not
aware of and I thought that we had a
really interesting conversation about
how that worst case scenario mode is
actually often how we also draft
legislation while it may be different in
case law when when Public Interest
lawyers are drafting legislation we are
looking for who are the most vulnerable
how could this fail and who could it
affect and so I think that actually we
have some very common mechanisms and
approaches when folks are drafting
patents or drafting legislation it
actually is quite at least from our
initial conversation there is some
similarity of narrative and language
that we can we can learn to talk to each
other rather than past each other
so my responses are resounding yes
I hope that it's broad and I hope that
I'll get to be helpful in whatever ways
might be useful so thank you just a few
thoughts one is that I think it's really
when we look at these set of questions
and I think these case studies are
really
interesting is to ask what is lost in
translation when we are taking a duty of
care that is the legal concept and we
qualify it for instance and I think that
one has to do with you know one of the
thing that comes to mind is signaling
where the normative power or open or
right and so it you know a duty of care
that is formalized for autonomous cars
is that actually automating something
right you you sort of think of that
machinery like autonomous car is talking
to one another when we think about norms
we think about also the signal the way
in which autonomous agents need to
direct their behavior and so sometimes
this is maybe they are exposed ex-ante
of you or and I think that going back to
Solon's the remark yesterday about what
makes AI different I think that when we
we don't have a justification for that
right people autonomous agents need to
have some idea why it is that they need
to behave this way or another and
sometimes when we look at these formulas
maybe this is good for Tony's course and
not that helpful for human beings
I'll just go ahead put my head now look
like I don't know whatever is the
question I have is about how we will
actually design things because I can
imagine that car companies may have an
interest in designing duty of care in a
way so that they're not legally liable
which is different from like
interpreting the law as a kind of
normative normative norm but write it
like and we see this in privacy
engineering all the time privacy
engineering is making sure you look
compliant but that doesn't mean you're
protecting privacy they're two different
things and so I'm wondering how we take
into account the kind of interests of
the companies to optimize for certain
functions including for example as
little legal trouble as possible or just
like that potentially the objective
rather than the constraint at some point
and how we deal with that Delta between
those things or is anybody even thinking
about like adversarial design so I think
if I can say I'm worried that I think at
this point of things that they're trying
to sell people on them on self friggin
cars is maybe a point that they're
really thinking about social welfare
about whether there's liability is if
there's actually statutory law that
requires certain things and the
enforcement is such that it was not
followed there's liability I mean
statutory law is very much about
avoiding the harm rather than after the
fact so that's it that's a huge
difference I think that perhaps there's
sometimes a generation between case law
or constitutional law which is after the
harm versus statutory law when for
drafting statutory law we are always
looking at let's avoid the problem and
let's incentivize the companies not to
create a situation which could cause run
but they thought the example number one
I don't remember now how we formulate a
book so long asks this question like is
it to avoid accident or is it to show
that you had to care for me I'm not sure
if that is avoiding harm in the sense of
harm to the driver and the company or if
it's harm to the outside quite crash
into the other car having damage and it
depends how it's crafted yes but I
thought that was like a really good
example of how you could totally
interpret but in adversarially out of
lack of better word right
Jamie yeah I just think a nice
counterpoint is the question so
definitely stuff get lost in translation
when computer scientists try to
formalize legal doctrine even if they're
talking to lawyers but I think also and
especially in the self-driving car
context the thing one thing we need to
be really careful about is that our
mathematical formulations also lose a
lot of reality when writing down our
formalisms so like you know I was trying
to think about what was bothering me not
about you know about this work that you
presented and I think the fact that like
there's no nothing nothing works if
there's like errors and estimation and
and that's not to say that like that's a
problem with what you presented it's a
problem of like somehow like this
formalism ignoring the fact that it will
be incorrect always and maybe formal
methods has something to say about this
I'm not a formal methods person but I
think it's really critical that we think
about like what we can say when our
models are wrong yeah it's not yes but
not quite yeah another formal methods
person either but I think that the kind
of aspects of this where your mom
capturing physical and sort of
uncertainty about physical quantities
that's something that people have
thought a lot about it yeah yeah yeah
artisanal easy to nail down what that
might be but I think your point you've
taken more broadly he's very much still
applies which is like somehow you need
your system to be able to handle the
disconnect between the abstraction and
way it's going to be applied and it's
like by definition and sort of thinking
about the abstraction
yeah so there's almost like a
fundamental impossibility possibility
there right right and they have to kind
of be suitably humble about and computer
scientists are notoriously good about
being humble but can I just ask before
you go on you said that this has been
covered like the physical uncertainty of
environment control theory all right
yeah real-time systems and very cyber
physical systems lots of lots of places
but machine learning sort of likes to
ignore as much of that as possible I
just like this is very interesting thing
about listen like a longer or history of
like that people be training to do this
kind of work like especially like with
Nicola saying like there's this kind of
established notion of technologists that
goes to work in the policy world and
that has traditionally meant like
someone trained in like a trillionaire
you do all the main computer science who
has expert knowledge that they then like
communicate to policymakers and
advocates so they better understand the
technology and then better know how to
apply fixing laws better know how to
develop appropriate regulations or
policies that's like extremely different
than what we just been talking about I
think like I actually think by trying to
develop the people to do this kind of
work is a completely different process
like we're not asking people to say like
here are the fundamentals of crypto and
therefore this policy doesn't make sense
we're actually asking people to become
like the engineers to encode normative
values and I really think the training
that we you would want for people to do
that is very different than just simply
saying like you know your policy for
security is ridiculous because it's
completely detached from the reality of
the technical process and I worry a
little bit too about how like the
orientation we might take and figure out
how to train these new people is to like
think about how like everything needs to
be channeled into the formalisms
of computer science when like I actually
think that one of the most difficult
tasks actually is even
recognize that the problem is and that
requires like not computer science
education and so it's like to be able to
discover identify interesting things to
work on not just because they're
computationally interesting but because
like they're relevant to the world and
they reflect real normative problems I
don't really know how to do that kind of
education well like I don't really know
people who I would say embody like this
remarkable mix of things and so I really
look like the existing infrastructure we
developed for Public Interest
technologists is not really well-suited
to developing prototypes of people yeah
I mean I would so having as you know I'm
a lawyer by training but I have had on
my team
both technologists as well as folks who
were computer scientists and lawyers and
folks who have been computer scientists
and social scientists together in one of
the things that I've been talking about
about this new university network is
that when if you're just treating
technologists and then drop them into
organizations you're actually continuing
to silo because what happens is the
folks who actually know all the
substance if it's 90% substantive and
10% technology those folks will still
send the tech work to the quote-unquote
technologists because they'd be all
intimidated by the technology and so
finding a way rather than doing that
finding a way that we're actually
creating collaborative interdisciplinary
training at the academic level so we are
sending folks out into into the role
that actually see those issues and can
communicate together from both sides so
technologists understanding the
Jews as well as folks who are not
technologists not being intimidated and
being able to connect with the
technology issues that is my hope for
this new initiative and I've been
talking to people about that because my
experience has been that it is not
useful to just put technologists and so
it actually takes a lot of years and I
know two or three of them that have been
very successful but it's taken you know
Chris ago and Chris constantly you know
a decade or more Peter actually till
they can actually do that effectively so
we can talk more about it
but I'm optimistic and hopeful if we can
do it right can we propose that the rest
of the discussion happens over coffee
and boundary breaks so that we have time
to do before we come back here